clark county school is back in session
in person this fall the district is
opening registration for the next school
year and wants you to be ready bianca
holmen live this morning with options
even if some families bianca aren't
ready necessarily to send their kids
back to campus bianca exactly
john maybe they want to continue
learning from the kitchen table in the
fall and that
option is possible and there for them
but you know the past 13 months have
been very difficult for
teachers students and parents and the
fall they're trying to make things as
normal as possible
but again the parents and families you
will have the option to either go
full time in person or continue with
distance learning so
this announcement was made yesterday by
ccsd and while most students are
expected to return
to campus full time there's still an
option for distance learning the
deadline to get
students into remote learning is one
month from tomorrow may 21st
the district wants to get all the
numbers in place as early as possible
and families do decide to choose the
online learning option there's going to
be
some changes students will be required
to have their cameras on the entire time
they're in class elementary kids they'll
need an adult at home that will be able
to attend
to their issues if they have any and
students will need to come into school
for some in-person events now here is
the ccsd website ccsd.net
and if you just scroll down you'll see
there's a tab
in the center of the screen where it
says register and you can now register
for the 2021-2022 school year so you
just click on that
and you're able to get your student all
squared away for
the fall and again that school year
starts on august 9th
back to you guys in the studio